plus de cinquante huit mille personnes
un hippodrome bondé plusieurs milliards
de téléspectateurs
le prix de l'arc de triomphe est
toujours une fête de play to be et cette
année la 94e édition porte est en plus
un nom
trèves adulé comme jamais aucun autre
galopeurs 13 portés par une foule de
supporters enflammé très beau passionné
au point de faire de l'ombre au
vainqueur de la course
comment en est on arrivé là retour sur
un phénomène médiatique
tout commence à chantilly lorsque le
propriétaire et l'entraîneur de trêve
réalise que la jument après quelques
ennuis de santé est revenu au meilleur
de sa forme
il décide alors de la préparer à un
triplé historique qu'elle gagne ou pas
trêve sera quoiqu'il arrive le premier
cheval de course au monde a disputé
trois fois l'arc de triomphe de trion
c'est quand même une des plus belles
courses que vous puissiez gagner au
monde
à mon avis c'est la plus belle parce que
c'est une course tiers de l'ancienneté
c'est une course qui vous a soit une
carrière d'un cheval
même s'il ya des courses mieux dotées
dans le monde aujourd'hui
elles n'ont pas l'aura que peu à voir
l'arc de triomphe et c'est ainsi que tu
rêves devenus follow trêve a pris la
tête d'une communauté 2.0
comptant à ce jour plus de 174 mille
fans
c'est une idée originale qui a été
proposé par le propriétaire de trêve des
promoteurs qui sont des qatari et en
voyant qu'elle progressait plutôt bien
pendant ses entraînements ils ont eu
envie de faire partager et de montrer un
petit peu faire sur cette aventure au
plus grand nombre
et le meilleur moyen c'est effectivement
les réseaux sociaux et ça a marché à
40000 like trêve a ouvert son club de
supporteurs à 50000 france galop a
accepté de le réserver une tribune à
longchamp du jamais vu et à 100000 live
trêve a offert un film à ses fans un
entraînement dans les rues de paris
la vidéo a été vue 290 1000 fois dès la
première semaine
oui la jument elle est capable d'amener
un nouveau public d'amener des jeunes
puisque on sait que le jeune public va
les chercher sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est ce qui a été fait malheureusement
tout le monde n'est pas prêt à jouer le
jeu ce qui est un tort à mon avis qu'on
est très ouvert on parle avec tout le
monde
alors ça peut nous est reproché sans
doute par certaines personnes par
d'autres ses amis et les gens son avis
quand on leur parle savez sans les
parieurs sans le public on ai rien à
cirer fait beaucoup pour les courses
hippiques
parce qu'il avait été sur les plateaux
télé mais mal à sa grande époque on
espère effectivement que le fait que
l'âge du monde dans l'histoire remonte
un petit peu tout cela dans les médias
et que on parle encore un peu plus des
courses et qui tend dans les médias
généralistes trêve de fait a attiré 600
journalistes à longchamp et fait la une
de nombreux quotidiens
côté produits dérivés elle n'est pas en
reste non plus sacs écharpes casquettes
poster et un bonus pour les supporters
qui avaient réservé leur place sur
internet un welcome pack plein de jolies
surprises
voici comment
merci au revoir
un petit drapeau le bracelet
qui permettra de garder un souvenir de
cette intro n'espère historique le 4
octobre 2015 et le petit flou que vous
ne pouvez trouver nulle part ailleurs
parce qu'il n'est
vraiment pour les supporters ne peut pas
l'acheter trêve a été battu par plus
fort qu'elle on le sait mais son
challenge d'un triplé historique a pesé
de tout son poids sur la présence des
spectateurs à longchamp comme sur les
paris il y a bel et bien eu un effet
trêve et un effet aide
ce 4 octobre 2015 la pouliche et son
entraîneur ont fait des merveilles et
donner plus aux bourses et aux
supporters qu'aucun autre tandem elles
resteront à jamais dans le coeur de
leurs fans